κύρισα και δεν επιχείρηση και κανένατααι κανένακαι να κλείσουμε τις εζήρησει με το άλμα μα
να δημια αδικήσου να δημιούργημα το κυριά ποτιναυτό το άλμα προέκυψε όταν αφού έχω κάνει
κάποιες προσπάθειες τέσπάτων και με τον συλλόγομου τον γάσειο να μπόμε σα να βοηθήσω και
λοιπά δυστουχώς δεδεν έκαννα δεν ξέρω τι μετά με την ομοσποντία οποίο εγώ πήγα κοντά
να μιλήσω και συζητούσαμε εδώ και πάνω που εφθαμήνες όπου τελικά πάλητε καταλύξησαμε έτσι ήταν
και περίόδος η δύσκολη που είχα που αναφέρει πρι αποφάσει σα υβραλιο τητον κυριάκον τοηδύναμη
μου και έτσι είπα ότι πρέπει να κάμω κάτι θέλω να ένιωθα ότι την ανάγκι
ότι πρέπει να προσφερω πρι να δώσω κάτι πίσω τις εμπειρίες μου τις γνώσεις μου
και λοιπά έτσι διμειουργεθηκε η άλμα από μιαν ομάδα ανθρώπον γνώστες του χώρου και τους
ευχαριστώ πάραβολύ ατι είναι και φίλη μου γραμματική με βοηθήσαμε πάρα πολύ δεν έκαμα μια
αναπλή να κάτι μια γιατί μπορεί να δήσει σε πάρα πολλέ ακάτιμή δεν είνα κάτι
απλών απλά έκαμα λέω ότι γυμνά ζωμορά και ανομορά ισπράπτο χρήματα και λιπάει έγινε ένα
σωματίο το οποίο έχουμε πιστοποιηθεί αποτευπουργιον εσωτερικό έχουμε ο πί στον μητρόν του κόα έχω
παρειόλες τις πιστοποιήσεις δουλεύουμε όσον το δυνατόν και με τους γιναστές που έχω όσο μας
επιτρέπεται στους χώρους που είμαστε όσον το δυνατό διαφορετικά και επαγγελματικά να προσφέρουμε το καλύτερο
στα νέα παιδιά είναι πολικής επέντεο ζώδεκα χρονώ και το δύο λσικοστία θημουρικήθηκε τοοιδίο χσικοσιδο